well Tom I think you are becoming a rock
star huh no no keep working Tom good
afternoon welcome a year ago or so I
told I told Tom Friedman I fully
understood that given his tan is very
high Stan as the New York Times Foreign
Affairs columnist he would be writing so
frequently and sometimes almost only
about what seemed to be the chief
American foreign policy issue the war in
Iraq I was complaining and but I also
told him that I like many others truly
regretted that he had stopped being the
keen observer of globalization that he
used to be I said Tom it's sad that your
writings on globalization have become
one more in the long list of collateral
damages caused by the war he stopped me
and said hey Ernesto not so fast
I am planning and in fact working
already on a new book on globalization
how about that obviously he put me on
the defensive but after a few seconds of
hesitation I decided to go on the
offensive again and said well it does
the case Tom you must promise that as
soon as a book is published you come and
present it to our University in
consistency with his
varial bonhomie tom says that's a deal
last fall nyan chanda our global editor
raise your hand iron who is also an old
friend of optom and an AI nyan and i had
the privilege of having a long
conversation with with Tom Friedman at
our Center in which Tom graciously gave
us a some advanced presentation of the
ideas that he was writing in his new
book and reiterated his commitment to
come and present a book as soon as it
would be published well today ladies and
gentlemen Tom Friedman is honoring his
word again and he is here to tell us why
the earth is becoming flat what are the
consequences for countries like mine
Mexico but certainly the challenges that
this is also posing for countries as
powerful as the United States of America
so Tom welcome again and thanks for
being here
and it's so thank you very much it's a
it's a treat to be here I've been on the
road the last few days
presenting the book and of all the
events I've been doing this is truly the
one I've looked forward to most I don't
think the Yale community appreciates the
incredible gem that it has here in the
globalization center that ngayon Shonda
and Ernesto Zedillo have have put
together the Yale global website has
been a constant source of insight and
information for me so there's really
nowhere more that I would like to you
know begin talking about this book than
an event hosted by Ernesto and nyan and
my daughter also goes to school here so
what I thought I would do in the next
just sort of 30 minutes is try to just
give you the this a long book 488 pages
so try to just give you the core thesis
and if you all are uncomfortable over
there there's sort of room on this stage
and I don't you won't bother me if you
sit up there so yeah I don't want anyone
to wants to be in to be a I'm actually
to take off my jacket if you don't mind
um you know Ernesto's story about us
having this conversation probably about
14 months ago is is very accurate and to
really understand what this book is
about you have to understand where it
came from as readers of my column know I
became the Foreign Affairs columnist in
1995 and my interest in that column
really oscillated between kind of lexis
issues of technology and finance and
globalization and olivetree issues of
you know conflict and and traditional
geopolitics and I was in that kind of
you know oscillation mode I would go
from one theme to the other right up til
September 11th 2001 at which point I
really dropped the globalization theme
like a stone and really went off and
covered the nine
eleven wars a really from September 11th
on I I spent my whole time in the Arab
Muslim world trying to really understand
the roots of 9/11 and the impact of our
response to it and I took one trip I
think during those three years to
Silicon Valley I went out to visit a
startup company that some friends of
mine were involved in us it's cuz we
called Google and I did exactly one
column about Google and went back to
Kabul basically kind of metaphorically
and I realized I sort of lost the thread
of the globalization story anyways um
during this three-year period I started
doing documentaries for the Discovery
Channel in in coordination with the New
York Times and we did one on the roots
of 9/11 we did another on the wall that
Israel had built in the West Bank and
last January that is 14 months ago
January of 2004 we were sitting around
with our discovery team thinking about
what what to do next and at the time of
course the whole question of America's
image in the world was a big issue and I
thought well when we do something around
that and I had this idea that why don't
we go to call centers around the world
and interview young people who spend
their days imitating Americans on what
they thought of America I thought it
could make a very interesting kind of
double you know perspective and we were
literally budgeting that out where to go
you know Philippines you know here there
Costa Rica Poland when John Kerry came
out with his blast against Benedict
Arnold executives who engage in
outsourcing and that immediately
exploded the whole issue of outsourcing
onto the world stage and on the American
stage Business Week fortune Forbes of
Wall Street Journal the New York Times
everyone did series about outsourcing
and so just watching all that unfold in
a period of really a couple weeks I said
you know what stop why don't we why
don't we just go to Bangalore the high
tech capital of India the Silicon Valley
of India and let's do a documentary on
the other side of outsourcing
caius people that turn their cellphones
off if you haven't I'm just so your cell
phones pacemakers anything just turn
them off so very disturbing so we had
this idea that we would do a documentary
on the other side of outsourcing so off
we went on February 15 2004 - to
Bangalore and we did about 60 hours of
interviews in in a space of about ten
eleven days and through the course of
these interviews uh I basically got
sicker and sicker it wasn't the food
it was a dawning awareness that while I
had been sleeping something really big
had happened in this globalization story
and I had totally missed it it hit me
somewhere between the Indian
entrepreneur who wanted to do my taxes
from Bangalore and the one who wanted to
write my software from Bangalore and the
one who wanted to read my x-rays from
Bangalore and the one who wanted to
trace my lost luggage on Delta Airlines
from Bangalore that something had
happened in fact I wish I could show you
just the outtakes from these interviews
I'd be sitting across from Gerry Rao the
head of NASSCOM the Indian high tech
Association and he's literally saying
Tom I can do your taxes I can do your
family's taxes I can do your wife's
family's taxes from here and with me
saying Gerry what what did I miss I miss
something how can you be doing this what
did I miss
well the last interview we had was with
Nandan Nilekani the head of Infosys the
CEO of Infosys which is kind of the
Microsoft of India and we were non
Dunn's an old friend we were sitting on
the couch outside his office before the
camera started he said Tom I've got to
tell you the global economic playing
field is being leveled and you Americans
you're not ready oh I wrote that down in
my notebook the global playing field is
level anyways we went we did our
interview and after that got into our
Jeep and drove back to hotel with my
Indian driver driving barefoot over the
potholes streets of Bangalore and I just
kept rolling over in my head what nan
Dunn had said that playing field is
being levelled what he's telling me is
that the playing field is being
flattened oh oh oh my god he's telling
me the world is flat and he's citing
this as a great advance in human
development that we'd made the world
flat that evening I got on the phone I
called my wife from Bangalore and I said
honey I'm going to write a book called
the world is flat she thought I had
completely lost my mind but I came home
from that trip I called the publisher of
the New York Times mr. Saul's burger and
I said Arthur I have to go on leave
immediately because my framework on
globalization which I laid out in Lexus
the olive tree needs updating and if I
don't do that I'm going to write
something really stupid in the New York
Times and so we we sat down and we we
plotted out a plan and from that day on
beginning basically March 15th of 2005
now 2004 yeah 12 months ago basically a
little over 12 months ago I started this
book and I've been doing nothing else
since separating two columns a week okay
and it became a complete obsession for
me to get my mind around what had
happened and to answer that question now
the book opens the first chapter is
called appropriately enough while you
were sleeping
and the book begins by me noting that
Christopher Columbus actually set sail
in 1492 looking for a shorter route to
India that's where Columbus was going he
sailed west he had the Nina the Pinta
the Santa Maria he never did find India
but he called the people he met Indians
and we still call them that to this day
and he came home and told his wife honey
I've accidentally discovered the world
is round
I said offer India 512 years later I
knew just which direction I was going I
went east
I had Lufthansa business class and a GPS
satellite that popped up in my seat and
I came home and reported to my wife
honey I've accidentally discovered the
world is flat and what this first
chapter is about is all the encounters I
had first in India but then beyond I
went to Dalian China the outsourcing
capital of Japan now tens of thousands
of Japanese speaking Chinese get your
mind around that in light of the recent
headlines out of China
okay um tens of thousands of Japanese
speaking Chinese managing the
bookkeeping and back room now for
hundreds of Japanese multinationals and
American multinationals formerly based
in Tokyo and then I kept going east I
went to Colorado and needed to make a
plane reservation one day so I called
JetBlue most successful airline in
America I kind of knew what I was doing
a soms they flew from Washington to
Atlanta no they said had a wonderfully
friendly woman on the phone sounded a
little matronly I said man would you
mind could I ask you your name she said
sure my name is Betty I said Betty could
you tell me where are you right now she
said honey I'm up in my bedroom I got my
slippers on in my bathrobe and I'm
looking out at the most beautiful scene
of Salt Lake City
because JetBlue has completely
outsourced this reservation system to
retirees in the Salt Lake City area
so when you when you call JetBlue for
reservation you may get Betty or Bob or
Susie up in their bedroom or in their
kitchen or around the dinner table
because they're making your reservation
on their home computer Jet Blue was
founded by a man named David Neil ermine
who's a develop Mormon who believes
families would be held together better
if parents were able to work at home and
so he has designed a complete home
reservation system that's who makes your
JetBlue reservation your phone call is
routed automatically to somebody in
their bedroom so I kept moving east got
got back home to Washington read a piece
in The Washington Post about McDonald's
new pilot project how when you drive
into McDonald's now and you go to the
drive-in thing and you press the button
say it like you know three Big Macs six
milkshakes eighteen fries you're not
speaking to the people in that
McDonald's you're speaking to a
McDonald's call center in Colorado
that's taking down your order and taking
your picture and they flash your picture
together with your order back into that
McDonald's McDonald's discovery they
save 30 seconds on each order and drove
down their error rate by a significant
degree is just a beginning program it's
not everywhere but I kept bumping into
these flattening experiences kind of
around every corner so the this chapter
really ends with a meta argument the
meta argument underlying this book is
that there have been three great eras of
globalization one I call globalization
1.0 and I would argue that lasted from
about 1492 until around 1800 which is
the beginning of global arbitrage 1820
and that year of globalization really
Shrunk the world from a size large to a
size medium and that year of
globalization was really built around
countries globalizing a Spain
discovering the new world Britain
colonizing India Portugal in East Asia
the dynamic agent of globalization in
that era was the country you went global
through your country the second-grader
of globalization was from the early
1800s until 2000 yeah it
it just ended and that year of
globalization Shrunk the world from size
medium to size small and the dynamic
agent of change in that year of
globalization was not the country but
the company the multinational which went
global
in search of markets and labor so in
globalization 2.0 you went global
through your your company that was the
dynamic agent of globalization while you
were sleeping while I was sleeping
we entered globalization 3.0 from 2000
to the present why the book is called
the world is flat a brief history of the
21st century and this era this
globalization 3.0 is shrinking the world
from size small to size tiny and
flattening the playing field at the same
time only what's really new about this
serie you see it's not built around
companies globalized and it's not built
around countries globalizing the new new
thing in this era is that the dynamic
agent of globalization in this era is
the ability of individuals and small
groups to globalize so we've gone from a
globalization built around countries to
one built around companies to one
increasingly built around individuals
and small groups and be advised it ain't
going to be a bunch of white Western
individuals who dominated globalization
1.0 and 2.0 it's going to be individuals
of every color of the rainbow who are
going to be able to plug and play so
that's really kind of the the meta meta
theme of the book the second chapter and
I'm just going to do the first three
just to give the kind of core thesis
then we can talk more about it the
second chapter of the book which really
took me the longest time is called the
10 days that flattened the world and
it's about the 10 really day's events
technologies and companies that came
together to actually create this level
playing field and let me go through them
for you quickly
um the first date is eleven nine eleven
nine eighty nine not nine eleven eleven
nine in a wonderful Kabbalistic accident
of dates the Berlin
all came down on 11 9 November 9 1989
and the fall of the Berlin Wall was a
huge flattener I called these the ten
flatteners because it allowed us to
actually see and think of the world as a
single flat plane
you know I would bet if we I mean Yale
didn't even think of having a
globalization Center before 1989 any
more than IBM would have described its
business plan as a global plan you had a
Western policy you had an Eastern policy
he had a northern policy had a southern
policy but no one was using the word
globalization before 1989 because there
was a wall in the way so the fall of the
wall was hugely important perceptually
for how people could think of the world
as a single seamless space now actually
call this flattener when the walls came
down and the windows came up because the
Windows operating system 3.0 the
breakthrough system shipped five months
after the fall of the Berlin Wall
so these two things happened at the same
time the wall came down and the windows
came up we suddenly had a single
graphical user interface with universal
application so that was the first
flattener the second flattener which I
consider to be one of the most important
days in our lifetime and in the lifetime
of this planet of equal importance to
eleven nine is eight nine ninety five
August 9 1995 August 9 1995 is a day a
small startup scope company in Mountain
View California called Netscape went
public and Netscape going public was a
huge flattener the for three reasons the
first reason is Netscape Netscape really
gave us the Internet yes yes the
Internet of course it was there is being
used by scientists but thanks to mark
end reasons remarkable invention of the
internet browser which allowed us to
actually illustrate on computer screens
all the data words music and information
locked away in websites it was the
internet browser invented by Netscape
which brought the internet alive so that
was the first important flattening
effect of Netscape second thing that
scape did a little more technical
Netscape actually commercialized a set
of open transmission protocols for the
internet so no company could dominate
the Internet and that helped make the
Internet so much more interconnected you
recall when you first got email your
wife was on CompuServe and you were on
AOL it was really hard to communicate
thanks to Netscape all those walls got
blown down and never came back the third
and most important thing course Netscape
did was trigger the dot-com boom which
triggered the dot-com bubble which
triggered the accidental over investment
of 1 trillion dollars in fiber-optic
cable in five years and that crazy wild
ridiculous absurd over investment in
fiber-optic cable
undersea and Overland accidentally made
Bangalore and New Haven and Bethesda
next-door neighbors without anyone
realizing what had happened it so drove
down the cost of transmitting voice and
words and data over fiber-optic lines
that it basically made it free and that
had a huge leveling effect Netscape went
public on eight 995 stock was priced
that day at $28 yet opened at 71 it
closed the first day at 56 everyone
looked at that and said there is gold
over them there hills
and every Yahoo from Global Crossing to
Lucent to fly-by-night Telecom said we
are going to lay fiber-optic cable
because the demand is going to be
infinite and they all tried to do it at
the same time and the accidental effect
was to drive down the cost of
telecommunications globally to virtually
zero now we went through a boom like
this in our own country you recall a
century ago with the railroads
there was a similar bubble and a similar
over-investment
there's one difference when we built the
railroads we got to ride for free when
we laid the global telecom network India
and China got to ride for free and this
was a huge flattener so in sum what the
Netscape moment did was bring people to
people connectivity to a whole new level
suddenly more people could connect with
more people more cheaply from more
different places than ever before
the third flattener is something i
simply call workflow and workflows my
name for all that software and all the
standards that connected all that
bandwidth with all those pcs and
workflows everything from Microsoft Word
to Microsoft NetMeeting
to proprietary software that any of you
have you know to run your businesses or
schools now again you'll go back just to
the mid 1990s in the mid 1990s Yale's
admissions department was running
Microsoft the the accounting department
though was running Novell each
department was much more efficient
because they had computers and email you
know there was just one problem the
admissions department couldn't
communicate with the accounting
department because applications did not
connect to applications well there was a
quiet revolution during the late 1990s
that basically enabled everyone's
application to connect with everyone
else's application no matter what
software you were running and no matter
what computer you were running it on so
you suddenly woke up one day and
discovered you could do a banking and
your bank didn't care what software you
had what computer you had and you didn't
care what computer the bank had or what
software they were running friends that
was a revolution because suddenly
everyone's applications could connect
with everyone else's applications which
meant suddenly people could work
together in manifold new ways so now we
come to the Genesis moment of the flat
world when you take the Netscape moment
you bring people to people together like
never before and then you take the
workflow moment and enable people to
connect applications with applications
like never before what we created
willy-nilly at the end of the 1990s was
a global platform for multiple forms of
collaboration suddenly more people could
collaborate on more different things
from more different places than ever
before off this platform now the next
six flatteners I argue are the six new
forms of collaboration that sprung from
this platform and flattened the world
even more the first is outsourcing whole
new form of collaboration now Yael if it
wants can take its accounting department
and move it to North Dakota to Mexico
City or to Bangalore either one is
equally easy yeah on this platform
outsourcing new form of collaboration
second new form of collaboration is
offshoring I built each one of these
around a date so I build the outsourcing
around y2k my build the next one
offshoring around China joining the
World Trade Organization now I take my
whole Factory and move it from Canton
Ohio to Canton China and integrated into
my production chain offshoring whole new
form of collaboration third new form of
collaboration is open sourcing bunch of
geeks sitting at home maybe some people
in this room working online for free
writing the next operating system Linux
open sourcing whole new form of
collaboration I mean how would you like
to be Bill Gates well how would you like
to be Bill Gates actually your whole
business model all these years is that
any company rises up to challenge you
you underpriced them you undercut them
one day you wake up and you discover
that Linux has 15% of the world
operating system market and it's sold
for free
it's hard to beat free it's hard to
undercut free now what is this open
sourcing about well some of its driven
by people a lot of it's driven by people
who hate Microsoft okay um and a lot of
it is driven by scientists who love the
pure science of it and the peer review
look at this algorithm I came up with
look at this patch I came up with and
that's a big part of the open-source
movement but it is becoming a whole new
industrial model of production in the
book I profile brian behlendorf the
young man from berkeley who drove the
apache web server project yeah all your
computer's run on Apache that's the
webserver that goes from your computer
and gets that thing out of your website
every computer needs a web server in
order to dish up websites and Apache was
a completely open source project that
basically developed a web server so good
that IBM eventually threw in the towel
junked its own commercial server and
sent its engineers to join this
open-source chatroom in fact as I tell
the story in the book IBM at first they
said lunch as silly College geeks will
give them the B team that took about one
day and the Apache people sent the IBM
people back home so you send us the
a-team okay what you're sending of this
junk we're not going to use this so a
lot of I know they've got a big stage
crowd here but I guarantee you everyone
under 20 to here knows what Firefox is
about ok Firefox is the hottest new web
browser it now has five percent of the
global web browser market in one month
Firefox was produced in an open source
collaboration between a 19 year old at
Stanford and a 24 year old in New
Zealand I have no idea whether they've
ever even met in one month the first
month Firefox was put up it was
downloaded 10 million times
ok I mean it's the hottest thing on
college campuses today so open sourcing
in my book I in reading this book I use
Wikipedia constantly which is an open
source encyclopedia where people around
the world send in entries you know
somebody's
written ernesto zedillo s biography
there someone wrote in and corrected it
you know maybe misses a deal you know
maybe misters a deal
Ernesto son then wrote in and changed
the spelling of his name and you know
got that right but this is a completely
globally produced open-source
encyclopedia and is certainly replaced
in Carta in my and my computer so open
sourcing whole new form of collaboration
the fourth new form of collaboration I
build around Walmart and this I simply
call supply chain where you design a
global supply chain down to the last
atom of efficiency the likes of which
we've never really seen before
so you take an item off the shelf at the
Walmart in West Haven and another exact
replica that item is immediately
produced in Shenzhen China if Walmart
were company sorry if Walmart were
country today it would be China's eighth
largest trading partner ahead of Canada
and Australia so we're talking about a
supply chain down to the last atom of
efficiency whole new form of
collaboration empowered by this world
the fifth new form of collaboration this
was the one that was the most
interesting for me to discover and learn
about is their agency writing this book
if you go to the acknowledgments you'll
see that the first two people
acknowledge my two primary tutors for
this book were two Indian entrepreneurs
Nandan Nilekani of Infosys and his
archrival vivec Paul the president of
Wipro which are the two leading Indian
outsourcing firms in in Bangalore and
which itself is kind of an interesting
story I interviewed one person in the
Bush administration to write this book
and I live in Washington DC okay but the
people who really broke the code for me
um were two Indian entrepreneurs who
were really in the epicenter of this
anyways I was in Beijing and I got an
email last June from nan Don who said
I've got another flattener for you you
have to add ups so I really didn't know
what he was talking about but I got home
and went down to UPS and and then I
discovered exactly what he was talking
about so UPS is my fourth flattener my
fifth flattened excuse me it does
something called that I call in the book
in sourcing
and insourcing is I come right inside
your company right up to your neck right
up to your headquarters and I take over
your entire internal logistics so say
you have a Toshiba laptop and it breaks
one day and so you go to the warranty
and it says call 1-800 help so you call
1-800 help and it says take your Toshiba
laptop down to the UPS store send it to
us and we'll fix it no problem what you
don't know is your Toshiba laptop goes
from the UPS store to UPS hub at
Louisville Airport in Kentucky we're in
an airline hangar at Louisville Airport
in a cleanroom a UPS employee repairs
your Toshiba laptop it never touches the
hands of Toshiba you go to Nike comm you
want to get a new pair of sneakers for
the kids UPS answers the email um
they're on the other side of the screen
they pick and pack the shoes they ship
them they collect the money see the Papa
John's Pizza truck robot
guess who's driving it someone in funny
brown shorts okay
UPS today is inside okay
hundreds and hundreds of companies who
no longer ever touch their products
anymore
they are simply marketing shells and
everything has been in sourced to ups
this is a whole new form of
collaboration which is going to become
an incredible flattener because the
standards to make this work seamlessly
have a huge flattening effect that's the
fifth so now we have it to say we got
outsourcing offshoring open sourcing
supply chain II and in sourcing that's
five I said there are six the sixth I
simply call informing and informing is
um a new form of collaboration that
really my name for Google Yahoo and
Microsoft search because I can now
inform myself I can collaborate with
data and mined data all by myself so
that's really nine we've got the first
three they create the platform we've got
the next six they really are the new
forms of collaboration that spring from
this platform the tenth as I said there
are ten flatteners I simply call the
steroids and excuse me the steroids are
wireless and voice over the internet and
what these steroids do is turbocharged
all six of these new forms of
collaboration so now I can do anyone
from anywhere with any device totally
mobile II now the next chapter the book
is really in some ways where I just tie
all of this together it's called the
triple convergence and the simple
argument here and I'll end with this
chapter is that sometime right around
the year 2000 there was a triple
convergence three things converged the
first thing that converged were all ten
of these flatteners right around the
year 2000 a tipping point was reached
and all ten flatteners started to work
together
the complementarities between them all
started to reinforce each other so the
outsourcing was enabled by the
informally the informing helped the open
sourcing the open sourcing drove the in
sourcing the complementarities between
all these flatteners started to work
together
and that friends is what I argue flatten
the world that is what flattened the
world because the product of that first
convergence was a web-enabled
global platform for multiple forms of
sharing of work and knowledge
irrespective of distance time geography
and increasingly even language that is
the moment when the world got flat the
second convergence I said there were
three is that we're now learning we're
just at the beginning of this to
horizontal eyes ourselves we're all
learning to interact with this new
platform horizontally rather than
vertically that is we're moving from a
world where value is created in vertical
silos of command and control to a world
where value is increasingly being
created in horizontal collaborations of
connect and collaborate now there's a
very famous economics article by Paul
David of Stanford who asked the question
when when electricity first came out
electric motors why didn't we get a
boost in productivity and his answer was
because people had to actually redesign
factories around small electric motors
and away from big steam engines and
pulleys which required multi-story
factories so it was really only when
architects changed their designs
managers change their designs and we all
changed our habits basically that um we
got the most out of electrification so
what we're in the process of right now
is what I call horizontal izing
ourselves we're learning we're just at
the beginning how to collaborate
differently around this platform so can
you start standing see stuff yeah now
the best illustration I can give you
actually is a story that involves Yale
and this really will will bring it alive
to you it did to me as I said you know
my daughter is a I can finally say my
daughter's I'd be giving the speech you
know a couple weeks now say my daughter
goes to school in New Haven
my daughter's a student here okay so um
so I um and we live in Bethesda Maryland
now I know many of you from Maryland but
if you're are from Maryland you know
it's a complete pain in the butt to get
here from Bethesda you have to drive to
BW
by airport in Baltimore take Southwest
Airlines from Baltimore to Hartford and
then drive a hour from Hartford to New
Haven so les Springer is coming up to
visit my daughter in March and noise
bringing a couple bags of spring clothes
for and whatnot and I'm a big Southwest
fan and so we under if I may have flown
Southwest but you may know that there's
no reserved seats on Southwest you just
get a ticket that says a B or C you do
not want to be a seat on Southwest
Airlines okay especially if you're
taking a couple of bags of carry-ons
because there'll be no room in the bin
above the seat you don't even want to be
a B where you'll be stuck in the middle
no problem
I'm a hip guy I did that you ticket
thing you know called American Express
and you know got my e ticket on
Southwest well I arrived at BWI Airport
in Baltimore 95 minutes before my flight
because I was going to be an a because I
have my stuff for my daughter and I'm
stuck my credit card into the Southwest
e ticket machine and out came that
ticket and it said B I said son of them
this thing is fixed this is rigged this
is worse than Las Vegas there is no way
I'm a beat I'm here 95 minutes before
this flight there's no way I'm a be when
got my Cinnabon and sat in the back of
the beeline
well about 45 it's really distracting
you can you two stop Thanks okay
well about 45 minutes later they called
the flight and and then I saw it all the
A's seem to be getting on carrying
crumpled pieces of what looked like home
printer paper as if they had downloaded
and printed out their boarding passes
and barcodes at 12:01 a.m. the night
before well of course what I didn't
realize was that Southwest Airlines
thanks to this convergence had just
begun a program that says you can now
download and print out your boarding
pass at 12:01 a.m. the night before and
just show up at the gate with your home
printer paper all friends I looked at
that and I said Friedman you are so 20th
century
you are so globalization 2.0 think about
it in globalization 1.0 there was a
ticket agent when I moved to Washington
to get a ticket I used to have to go
onto the United Airlines office pull a
number out of the machine
wait in line there was a physical person
in front of me we did a transaction I
got my tickets then we got the e-ticket
machine we thought that was cool while
you were sleeping Southwest Airlines
made you the ticket agent and they made
you their employee and excuse me if you
value your own time staying up at 12:01
a.m. the night before you are paying
Southwest Airlines to be their employee
so all of that is a result of this
convergence but because I hadn't
horizontal eyes myself I hadn't changed
my habits to collaborate with Southwest
differently I didn't get any of the
productivity boost like a [ __ ] I showed
a BWI Airport in 95 minutes before the
flight wasting all that time basically
when I've had had a horizontal eyes
myself the night before
I could have gotten the productivity
boost we're just at the beginning of
this phenomena and it's happening in
every single industry but I said that's
the second convergence the third and
last convergence is that this flattening
happened happened to coincide with a
huge event in the world three billion
people called Russia China and India
walking onto the playing field and when
do they arrive on the playing field just
when it's been flattened just when they
and their kids can plug and play more
directly than ever before in the history
of the world yes yes I know maybe only
10% of those three billion can really
plug and play see 10 percent of 3
billion 1 carry the 0 that's 300 million
that's twice the size of the American
workforce so the simple thesis of this
book is that it is the convergence of
these 10 technologies and events with
these new business processes with these
3 billion new players that is really
going to define and shape the brief
history of the twenty-first century now
before I finish let me simply point out
that this flattening this triple
convergence of these technologies habits
and people coincided with a political
perfect storm and the political perfect
storm was called 911 and Ron and the
dot-com bust the dot-com bust made some
very silly people right that
globalization was over don't to think
about that anymore 9/11 completely
distracted us as a country and at an
administration and his journalists and
of course Enron made every CEO guilty
until proven innocent and therefore no
one wanted to think about or talk to
them so it was a really interesting
experience researching this book because
I everything I told you I didn't know a
year ago and I really learned from going
around interviewing people technologists
who were in the middle of it but but
these CEOs who are doing it they were
like it was like being in a
science-fiction movie they're like pod
people ok
they they know the secret okay they know
just what's happening and they're doing
it like crazy but nobody's told the kids
nobody's told the kids so right at a
moment when we have reached an
incredible inflection point we were
moving from a world of vertical to
horizontal nobody's talking about we
have a president who's trying to unravel
the New Deal at a time when we really
need is a new new deal to deal with a
world gone flat so nobody is we just had
an election where the Democrats were
debating whether NAFTA was a good idea
and the Republicans put duct tape over
the mouth of chief White House economist
Greg Mankiw
when he said outsourcing made a lot of
sense and stashed him in Dick Cheney's
basement so right when we've reached
this really defining transforming moment
of the beginning of the flattening
process nobody's talking about it the
debate about globalization is so out of
date I mean you know with all due
respect to the nation but you know these
magazines are dining out on the carcass
of a debate from about 1996 but IMF
conditionality and World Bank condition
I just met with a Indian a finance
official we said the IMF's begging us to
borrow money now we don't even think
about the IMF anymore and so the whole
debate about globalization hasn't even
begun to catch up with what's actually
been happening in the world so let me
simply end by saying I wrote this book
to tell the kids least tell my own kids
what I think is happening in the world
and what I think is happening was best
described by Carly Fiorina the former
CEO of HP
who said you know everything we call the
IT revolution these last 20 years sorry
to tell you just the warm-up act that
was just the sharpening forging and
distribution of the tools of
collaboration what you we're now just at
the end of the beginning what you now
are about to see is the real IT
revolution with the flow with what's
happened here so ladies and gentlemen
please fasten your seat belts put your
seat backs and tray tables into a fixed
and upright position because the world
is flat thank you very much
good
well Tom has agreed to take a few
questions let me use my privilege as
host and go back to an old argument that
Tom and I had had for many years I
believe everything that tom says in this
book but I would like to argue that all
of this which I think it's a wonderful
work
I think prosperity and even a peace and
security a good stem very powerfully
from this kind of globalization but the
other side of the story for me is that
all of these can be at risk and Tom
being as he calls himself I think in
page 374 he says I am a technological
determinist give me a charge you said it
here well I'm not a technological
determinist I think that indeed
globalization has been driven to a great
extent by technological advances but
also by political decisions and
political decisions to open up economies
to allow investment to to do many things
through those political decisions and
sometimes they are good but other times
they can be stupid and aren't we risking
all of this Tom by stupid political
decisions that could have stopped the
process or are you still a die-hard
374 374 I just have to read the next
sense the chapter is called the on flat
world this is so let me try to answer it
I am a technological determinist guilty
as charged but while I'm a technological
determinist I am NOT a historical
terminus there is absolutely no
guarantee that everyone will use these
new technologies or the triple
convergence for the benefit of
themselves their countries are humanity
these are just technologies using them
does not make you modern smart moral
wise fair or decent it just makes you
able to communicate compete and
collaborate farther and faster in the
absence of a world destabilizing war
every one of these technologies will
become cheaper lighter smaller and more
personal mobile digital and virtual
therefore more and more people will find
more and more ways to use them we can
only hope that more people in more
places will use them to create
collaborate and grow their living
standards not the opposite but it
doesn't have to happen to put it another
way I don't know how the flattening of
the world will come out indeed this is
the point in the book where I have to
make a confession I know the world is
not flat
but I have to tell you unfairness
dernesto and his question that chapter
was very much stimulated by not only
Ernesto's questions but when you read
the book you'll see his input because we
have had this conversation for a long
time and Ernesto knows from personal
experience as someone who had to try to
manage NAFTA how politically explosive
the backlash can be and especially when
the world goes flat and we now have a
whole new group of people who could be
affected not just blue collar workers or
white collar workers and and knowledge
workers who who also vote and write
op-ed pieces for The New York Times and
and that's why I think and I quote
ernesto in the book as making the point
which he just provocatively made here as
saying there's you know the chapter that
that this is all in is called no guns or
cellphones a lot and it's a sign from a
health club in Minneapolis where I might
grow because Minnesota passed a law a
couple years ago saying that you could
bring a handgun or a weapon into a
public place unless they explicitly had
a
on the door that said no guns allowed
and then health clubs discovered that
people are bring cameras into locker
rooms unfortunately taking pictures of
people with their clothes off and then
emailing them around the world so they
really just put it two together there
one after the other no guns or cell
phones allowed and I really use that in
my head to simply say yeah I'm a
technological determinist if people have
the technologies they will use them but
what they will use them for is not
predetermined and that's why I think
it's so important that's why I agree
with their nesto that we have to tell
the kids
and we don't have to tell the kids and
the way to say this is not there's
something it's not the lou dobbs way
okay something terrible a terrible
tragedy is we have to educate people and
we have to create what I call the new
New Deal that will make more people
employable here and abroad when the
world goes flat and I actually lay my
own philosophy out in the book which I
call compassion at flat ism and I go
through the different things we need and
of course the first thing I argue is a
new kind of leadership a new Pennell
leadership that doesn't use what's going
on in the world to frighten us to make
us stupid but to try to educate us on
what's going on out there
where are the incredible opportunities
you know we're connecting all the
knowledge pools in the world together
that's one meaning of the flat world
when Bangalore is connected to Yale when
food on University I've just been on
President Levin's international advisory
board and we this morning all we heard
are about the incredible collaborations
Yale is now doing with food on
University on genetics and empowered and
enabled entirely by a flat world so
we're connecting all the knowledge pools
in the world together that's really
exciting the next great breakthrough and
bioscience could come from a 15 year old
in Mexico City who downloads the human
genome but this the the frightening
thing about this are the challenging
thing about it is that you do have to
constantly be upgrading your your
knowledge skills in order to get a share
in this world
and that's true whether you're in India
or in Mexico or in New Haven it's also
true if you're a journalist I just spent
the last year retooling myself and I
spent the last year in Bentonville
Arkansas with Walmart in Louisville
Kentucky with ups in Bangalore with wit
Pro and Infosys all I've been doing
lassi the last year is really just
completely retooling myself out of sheer
panic because if I didn't upgrade sort
of my own knowledge skills I wouldn't be
able to write a column that would be
able to make sense of the world and so I
have great sympathy with anyone else who
has to do this and I have a lot easier
time doing it because I can manage my
own time it's not like I'm working for
someone who can limit my time but the
main argument here and in response to
Ernesto's point this to me is the
discussion we should be having in the
country right now not about privatizing
Social Security that's that's a complete
ideological jag okay we need to be
talking about the world as it really is
what are the challenges it poses and
what are the incredible opportunities it
holds out that's what we should be
talking about right now and that's you
know one of the debates I hope to
trigger with the book Ernest
oh yeah we'll just go ahead yeah I'm in
a favorite students if that's okay you
look I hope your student could I see
your ID please sorry auntie bull yeah
it's a really important question
um I don't frame it in terms of Union
non-union so but my the kind of
priorities I lay out in this in my own
sort of compassionate flatted first
level section on leadership which I
simply say we have to have leaders who
are educators who tell us who described
the world to us as it really is okay and
and that we all know I don't have to
belabor that what kind of political
discussion we're having in this country
and and just the level of it how
disconnected it really is from the world
around us um then I kind of break it
down into what I call muscles and fat
okay there's new muscles we have to
acquire and to me the first I believe we
should have national health care
personally but until we get that one
thing we absolutely must have is fully
portable health care so no one should be
trapped in a job for a dying company and
I feel sorry for anyone working for a
General Motors right now or whatever you
know that people have got to be able to
be as mobile and flexible with their
health care we have to have fully
portable health care - we have to have
fully portable pensions so I can pay it
at this company and then take it and
move to the next company okay so I can
take advantage of of growth where it is
that's what I think of in in terms of
partly in terms of muscles the third
thing I believe we need is wage
insurance for about seven billion
dollars a year
and this really is chump change in the
budget we could have a program Bob
lighten and Laurie klutz are from
Berkeley have designed a whole program
for wage insurance that doesn't fully
compensate you if you lose your job to
outsourcing or to foreign trade but does
give you a far bigger cushion than you'd
have now not only gives you a cushion
but actually encourages you to take a
new job and you actually
you'll get you know $10,000 over a
certain period of time or 10,000 over
over a couple years depending on the
situation you're in that encourages you
to take a new job quickly which is
actually the best way to get new skills
the fourth thing I think we need is
tertiary education post-secondary
education I believe that it was the high
school movement that got us you know 150
years ago 98% of Americans worked in
agriculture today 2% work in agriculture
how did we get all those people from one
to the other from the agricultural world
to the mechanical world industrial world
we did it by making everyone go to high
school I believe now we have to enable
everyone to have post-secondary
education that if we're thinking how we
should be spending our money it should
be to create either subsidy tax break or
whatever that any American who wants
post-secondary education can get it and
then I go through a whole section about
what companies can be doing to rescale
people in order because we have a new
social compact now it's no longer
lifetime employment no one can guarantee
you that but that I believe the new
social contract between government and
individual and company and individual
should be lifetime employability that by
gosh while you're here I'm going to
guarantee you the educational
opportunities either inside this company
which will make you more valuable to me
if I can teach you a lot of different
skills or make you more valuable to
somebody else outside here through
lifetime learning possibilities and the
last thing I call for is new parenting
we're now blending in where the world's
gone flat and we're now meeting up with
with two cultures in particular Chinese
and Indian culture that have a huge
value on education and you know there's
no getting around this mom dad throw
away the game bling um shut off the TV
as I've said I've nauseum you know when
I was growing up my parents used to say
to me Tom finish your dinner people in
China and India are starving and I say
to my girls girls finish your homework
people in China and India are starving
for your jobs okay so there's one
entitlement we do really need to get rid
of
and that is our sense of entitlement
because in a flat world they eat no such
thing is an American job there's just no
such thing but the good news it no such
thing is an Indian job or Mexican job
either I mean you know it's going to be
there but you have to globalize yourself
you have to think of yourself as
competing against and with a much wider
work force so those are the kind of
things I don't pretend they're
comprehensive but I'm trying to kick off
a discussion and I don't know where
unions you know fit into that or not but
that we at least talk about the world as
it is and what are some of the tools we
need to prepare our people for that
world so that's where I come from yeah
I've know behind you that the PM I want
to get the student if I could I'll come
back to the old guys
yeah to be up to get up there
you know I I don't want to pretend like
I have a magic cure for kind of every
problem that a very sight I have in this
problem sure huge gaps in this book but
to me a lot of it is about well first of
all explain to people the world they're
in and the world were in is that the
countries that will succeed are those
that have the best infrastructure with
the best education system with the most
investment friendly environment with the
most stable government so there's no
rocket science to this and whether it's
again Mexico America or Upper Volta or
it's not a revolt anymore whatever it is
you know it applies to everybody and so
you know one of the things I examples I
give because I used to be the key word
in all this is collaboration we're
moving this world where it's all about
how we collaborate and so I give the
example of different ways of
collaborating with different parts of
the world that are caught up in this so
this chapter the unflattering out of it
one I call the two sick okay
and that's communities and countries
caught up in hiv/aids malaria
tuberculosis these people are too sick
to collaborate and plug and play on this
platform second are the two unable
that's rural India rural China rural
Mexico they're kind of half flat in a
sense they've been to Mexico City
they've been to Bangalore they've seen
the big cars in the riches and the big
they'd like to be part of it but they
don't have the tools okay and so the
third group I call the two frustrated
and that's really the Arab world today
because when the world goes flat you get
your humiliation fiber optically okay
you get it at 56k right in the face
because in a flat world you can see just
where the caravan is and just how far
behind you are and that produces
enormous and dangerous resentments and
the fourth is too many Toyotas because
when three billion people walk onto the
flat world and they all have their own
version of an American dream a house a
car a toaster and a micro
if we don't find an alternative source
of energy we're either going to burn up
this planet or we're going to be in a
war with China over oil because if you
haven't noticed I mean China's foreign
policy day is very simple it's called
Taiwan and looking for oil that's it
yeah so so you know back really to your
to your question in the too sick part
actually talked about the Gates
Foundation and what they have done
looking for innovative ways to
collaborate with people in the to sick
communities in the to unable to hear I
really lay down a challenge to the
anti-globalization movement because I
believe what the anti-globalization
movement should be about today all that
energy and there was enormous energy
there moral energy okay but I believe it
was really squandered by it may have had
a moment before but it's completely
irrelevant now and you know dressing up
like a turtle and throwing a stone
through McDonald's window isn't going to
feed you know one person in the world
today but I don't want that energy to go
away
I think we're the anti-globalization
where the left should be on this issue
is understanding you know poor people
don't resent people rich people anywhere
nearly as much as the left sometimes
think what they resent is not having the
chance to get rich and you take a look
at India today here's a country that in
1991 before it adopted a globalization
strategy had a hundred million dollars
in the bank today it has a hundred
eighteen billion dollars in foreign
reserves that's great news but here's
the problem now when they budget a
million rupees from New Delhi to that
school just south of Bangalore by the
time it arrives at that school it's
fifty thousand rupees okay and I believe
where the anti-globalization movement
should be is focused entirely on local
governance transparency accountability
using the internet using all the tools
we have to trace every dollar that comes
out of Mexico City and where it ends up
in the countryside and every dollar that
needs New Delhi and where it gets to the
village my own personal feeling is
poverty is a governance issue
overpopulation is a governance issue
environmental degradation is a
governance issue you know that unless
you get governance that works you're
really not going to be able to tackle
any of these problems so that's where I
think to the extent that we in the
developed you know flat world think
about how we can help it's really there
the other example I give in that chapter
is HP did a very interesting project
they did a pilot project in a village in
India it's in the book I don't remember
the name where they it always starts
with listing the best collaborators are
listeners so HP sent a team out to this
village and so they simply live there
and said what do people need okay and
the answer they came up with after about
two months was that these people really
need someone to take pictures they have
all kinds of need for pictures for
licenses and whatnot and to get a
picture they have to walk an hour to the
next town so HP said no problem pictures
is us we do pictures we just send them a
bunch of you know cameras and and um you
know developed more machines great no
problem no electricity okay so the HP
sent their engineers outsourced
scratched their head well we can do this
so they created mobile photo labs using
solar panels okay designed the whole
thing you know came just out of
listening to the problems here and then
they went to a woman's NGO and said
we're going to rent this to you because
they really want to see what people
would do with it and so they rented it
to this women's group and they went out
they rented two of them they built two
and they rented and they went out
started using well it turns out Indian
villagers just like New Haven residents
love to have family pictures and they
want their weddings and their family
celebrations and and so suddenly these
women started making a wonderful little
business not just taking pictures for
farmers who need licenses but Grandma
and Grandpa and birthdays and weddings
and bar mitzvahs and whatever else you
know um so so this worked great and they
were thrilled they're making money from
it so six months went by and I tell the
whole story in the book I remember how
much
time and they HP came to the women's
group and said this is great this so
neat what you've done with it now we
want our camera back they said what what
do you mean you want your camera
backward I mean we got a nice little
business and HP said and they knew what
they were doing they said we're but
we're not an NGO we're HP okay we're
looking to make this a sustainable
business model so here's the deal you
find a way to pay us X amount each month
and you can keep the cameras and that's
what they did so they set up a payment
system where they you know rent them and
they pay them I think it's nine dollars
a month or whatever it is and then they
buy the paper and stuff so from HP's
point of view like if this takes off
that's a huge market you know um that's
what you want they don't want charity
okay the people don't want charity and
HP is not a charity so that's not
sustainable so it's looking for ways to
collaborate with people in really
creative ways that start by listening to
them first and then working the
technology back so yeah
right and human being son yeah it's an
interesting question did you hear that
she wants to know if there'll be a book
signing afterwards and there will be
thank you I'll be signing books
afterwards and they're all out there and
I'll be very happy to thank you so much
for your question no the question was
really we all crave human interaction
and what happens when you know we're
interacting but with more people but
really virtually is really the question
and I I'm not going to dodge it I just
have to say I think it's a really good
question and I don't know I think that
we're really at the beginning of
something and I and I say that many
times in the book I don't know where
this goes you know I think the job of
the analyst is to try to see something
and define it right when it's reached a
tipping point but other people haven't
seen it yet and that's what I've tried
to do here but I really say many times
in the book I don't know where this is
going and I think that's one of them one
of the areas all I can say to you though
is like in doing the book many I
realized I was I was both writing about
in interacting with this platform I mean
it was so neat like um so many people
like Rajesh rahu is a young Indian game
designer in Bangalore who today owns the
global rights to Charlie Chaplin's image
for cellphone games there's a 32 year
old kid in Bangalore ok who started from
nowhere and read his section in the book
it'll knock your socks off you know but
he and I God we exchanged an email at
2:00 in the morning and I may not have
been face to face but wow we were sure
connected like never before and uh and
I've had so many experiences like that
in writing the book that I don't feel
really impoverished you know um by this
but I might I just don't know I think
you're asking something very important
it's too early for me to tell really
yeah
right sure
right what will keep what will we keep
yeah it's a it's a good it's a really
important question again I don't know
because I think a were too early you
know in this but you know that my kind
of general model is this when the I
think what happens in simple economics
terms when the world goes flat like this
is the global market gets much bigger if
suddenly two compasses many more people
so that's really good if you sell the
kind of services or software or good
idea goods that can be actually sold to
everyone in the market at the same time
so if you sell Microsoft Windows so the
market gets bigger and the same time the
good news is it also gets more complex
and so because people often say my god
what's going to happen to my job and I
said I have a chapter in the book is
free trade still relish I believe in
free trade is that good for my kid
actually describe the scene of emphasis
at the shift change in Bangalore with
you know thousands of young engineers
going and thousands coming everyone
looks like they got 1600 on their SATs
you know and and I'm just sitting there
watching this sea of people coming and
going and then the emphasis spokeswoman
sidles up to me and says we had a
million applications last year for nine
thousand jobs have a nice day okay so
you think wow Jesus just good you know I
mean but that would only be bad if you
believed in the kind of lump of Labor
theory but there was one lump of labor
in the world we've had it and now India
and China are going to grab it you know
but that's actually not what happens and
what what really happens is um I know
there's some parents here and and so mom
dad don't be surprised if your son or
daughter comes home at the end of this
year and says mom dad I've thought about
it I really want to be a search engine
optimizer
when I grow up say what in the world he
couldn't you be a doctor a lawyer you
you you have to be a what is that well
you know in ten years ago there was no
such thing as Google today Google is
hiring mathematicians by the bushel okay
because they invented something called
search a whole new industry well then
somebody came along and said now if I
type in the word suitcase into Google
impress I'm feeling lucky
um and Samsonite comes up before Tom
Friedman suitcase company the benefits
to Samsonite are Monster benefits that
people see Samsonite before they see
mine so this has now spawned a whole new
industry called search engine optimizing
where I will work with you to get Tom
Friedman suitcase company up above
Samsonite well this Google is just math
it's just an algorithm so this combines
math and marketing it's a whole new
industry so this is going on every day
the challenge I think for us in terms of
the question you the worst thing I think
is going to happen to any yaeli who gets
a good education anyone who graduates
from the University of Minnesota is
you're going to have to move
horizontally that is some specialty we
had may go somewhere else and we'll
develop new niches and new specialties
if you don't have that education you've
got to move vertically and society's job
is to enable more people to move
vertically that's really the challenge
for us but remember you know after World
War two we stood astride the world you
know totally dominant and what we did
the craziest thing in the world we
rebuilt Europe into a competitor and
what happened our standard of living
grew six straight decades so I think the
same will happen you know to India and
China but this is a little bit of a
crisis and we've got to meet it
I think we're best in a crisis but as my
friend Paul Romer says a crisis is a
terrible thing to waste and we don't
want to waste this crisis thank you very
much